a lot of people have been writing me
they enjoyed right before we went on
break Holly weird squares and I thought
well maybe this would be a good
opportunity to play for you some of the
outtakes from Hollywood Squares you say
what do you mean outtakes wasn't it live
yeah but well [ __ ] goes on behind the
scenes we do uh we test people's
microphones and we always keep
everything recording so uh
first up Howard Stern impersonator Matt
friend now this is a this is very
interesting to me I was wondering how he
does that impression of me and it turns
out he's full-on Daniel Day-Lewis
he does not come out of character he was
running around as Howard Stern the
entire time while waiting to go on the
air and I have a clip of that I adjusted
the sunglasses to go down a little bit
right so maybe that can help something
with a little bit
yep that helps a lot right thank you
I'll be mindful of that when I'm on the
air by the way
appreciate it
I can't stop by the way I might actually
a little afraid right now that I can't
stop talking like him I gotta stop doing
this
you know Robin uh even I dropped the
Howard Stern character when I'm off you
don't talk like this all day long High
Pitch Eric signed on to zoom before the
show
and wasted no time trying to glom onto
Howard Stern impersonator Matt friend uh
right away high pitch had a scheme in
mind are you are you in New York I am
yeah
you do any shows in New York yeah I do
stand up like every night you should
come by shows sometime I'm at The Stand
Comedy Club all the time are the stands
is a good place if you ever if you ever
want me to introduce you on stage I
would I would love to have you come on
stage well not come on stage but you
should like come on the stage me and you
should go on tour you want me to go on
tour with me yeah man you're so on tour
we'll have to take a look at that all
right we'll have to take a look at that
we'll see what happens let's see how
this show goes
yeah this is hysterical
we'd be like Abbott and Costello but we
blew each other I'll introduce you and
then you'll go out and be funny yeah and
then we'll split the profits 50 50.
before we did Holly weird squares we
separated everyone into two different
Zoom rooms no one was for Christopher
Mad Dog Russo and Ike baronholtz okay
and the other Green Room is for everyone
else
[Laughter]
and uh Matt friend that's funny who is
Howard Stern impersonator and High Pitch
Eric were not happy that there was a VIP
Zoom room
and here you are again behind the scenes
where's Mad Dog Russo
Ike and mad dog are in another room
they're gonna get moved in here around 6
45 when I'm doing the whole talk with
everybody
there's a VIP section on the zoom is
that what's happening
[ __ ] I actually be here with us not in
the private yeah not in a private plane
room right [ __ ] VIP section well
maybe high pitch doesn't have a high IQ
but he certainly has a high ego factor I
mean
well who knew it first the Howard Stern
impersonator is like uh he's offended
well because he thinks he's Howard Stern
he's in character
oh for those of you who are wondering uh
because last week Eric I announced that
we had a High Pitch Eric had a
microphone set up and he threatened not
to give us back the microphone
and I had a straight amount on the air
so I just want you to know Eric did ship
back his microphone equipment last week
and then immediately blocked Derek who
works for a Sal who works for us Jason
and Will's telephone numbers because he
refuses to participate in any other Zoom
segments because it was too stressful
according to him yeah I just wanted to
add that you know trying to get this
equipment back from Eric was like
dealing with a hostage negotiation you
know like he said he wouldn't give us he
wouldn't be able to do it on a Thursday
or Friday because that's when all of his
favorite TV shows are and he would be
busy watching the TV shows uh you know
and then he's just uh you know basically
holding all of our equipment hostage but
he finally put it back in and now I
suppose we're all blocked so we won't be
able to get in contact with him uh
further for any other segment so I guess
that's the last we made of here from
high pitch for a while well uh you got
to give Derek the um the uh the medal of
freedom for dealing with high pitch and
uh having to Wrangle all that nonsense
but uh if you want you can watch the
full segment video now on the Howard
Stern section of the SiriusXM app